l'information était attendue par les
français elle est désormais officielle
le gouvernement a confirmé ce jeudi
après-midi la généralisation du
couvre-feu à partir de 18h sur
l'ensemble du territoire
cette mesure entrera en vigueur dès
samedi et pour une durée minimum de 15
jours il apparaît selon les données
disponibles à ce jour que cette mesure a
une efficacité sanitaires dans les 15
premiers départements où le couvre feu a
été mis en oeuvre à 18 heures le 2
janvier dernier la hausse du nombre de
nouveaux cas y ait deux voire trois fois
plus faible que dans les autres
départements métropolitains comme le
montre la carte qui s'affiche à l'écran
un temps évoqué un confinement le
week-end en plus du couvre-feu la
semaine n'a pas été retenu par
l'exécutif pour autant un nouveau
confinement généralisée n'est pas exclue
dans les prochaines semaines je veux
être parfaitement clair avec vous
si nous constatons dans les prochains
jours une dégradation épidémique forte
nous serions conduit à décider sans
délais d'un nouveau confinement
car nous devons comme nous n'avons cessé
de le faire depuis le début de cette
crise nous préparer à toute éventualité
du côté des écoles chaque classe mangera
chacune son tour afin d'éviter le
brassage des élèves dans les cantines
parallèlement les pratiques sportives
scolaires et extrascolaires en intérieur
sont désormais interdites pour les
mineurs du côté des universités la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur a
annoncé une reprise très progressive des
cours en présentiel
nous devons permettre aux étudiants de
renouer le contact en présentiel avec
leurs enseignants il est impératif que
nous puissions progressivement tracer
ensemble ce chemin qui nous permettra de
passer d'une majorité d'enseignement
distanciait là une majorité
d'enseignement en présentiel dès la
semaine du 25 janvier et travaux dirigés
pourront donc reprendre en demi-groupe
pour les étudiants de première année
c'est une étape sur ce chemin avant de
pouvoir réintégrer davantage d'étudiants
au sujet des secteurs de la culture de
la restauration et du sport aucun
changement
été annoncée théâtres bars musées
restaurants ou encore salles de sport
garderont leur rideau baissé jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
enfin la propagation du vaillant
britanniques continuent d'inquiéter le
gouvernement désormais les voyageurs
venant de pays hors union européenne
devront obligatoirement présenter un
test pcr négatif de -2 72 heures pour
entrer sur le territoire français par
les airs ou par la mer ces voyageurs
devront également s'engager sur
l'honneur à s'isoler sept jours à leur
arrivée puis passer un nouveau test pcr
à l'issue de cette période